[Musica]
francesca 6 la pecora nera della
famiglia
è l'estate del 2009
sto litigando con la persona che
definisco la mia dice mamma e le sue
parole mi colpiscono come uno schiaffo
appena messo nero su bianco una paura
che mi tormenta da tempo e che mai come
in quel momento stress è assolutamente
vera perché è l'estate del mio post
matura quella che dovrebbe essere fatta
di feste e divertimento avventure ma
io sono in punizione
sono uscita dal liceo con il 62 o meglio
come dicono i miei fratelli con un bel
calcio nel sedere
per fortuna che i voti non sono stati
pubblicati sui giornali anche perché io
vengo da una famiglia che finisce spesso
sui giornali ma con tutta altri
risultati mio padre gestisce il centro
commerciale più grande del friuli
venezia giulia mia mamma fa parte della
dinastia di distillatori che ha
rivoluzionato la grappa da prodotto
povero considerato affatto quegli scatti
del distillato che oggi rappresenta
l'eccellenza del made in italy nel mondo
anche i miei fratelli non sono da meno
colti grandi lettori tutti usciti con
più di 90
100 con quanto orgoglio ne parlano mamma
e papà quando si tratta di me
generalmente esclamano qualcosa tipo
francesca è un cuor contento è tanto
entusiasta mi sembra quasi una specie di
premio di consolazione
sono la pecora nera ma allegra in una
famigliari campioni ho 19 anni e so che
le scelte che sto per andare a fare
andare a determinare tutto il mio futuro
e di una cosa sono sicuro
voglio sentire di essere degni anche io
di questa famiglia
ma come
quando penso alle mie qualità penso di
essere una persona entusiasta empatica
con quella che mi piace definire una
creatività affettiva da quando sono
piccola
ogni volta che si avvicina il compleanno
di una delle persone a cui voglio bene
vengo presa da una sorta di fiamma
creativa che mi spinge a dover preparare
qualcosa dove fanno loro capire quanto
importante per me quanto sono speciali
ma i tempi non si parla ancora di
intelligenza emotiva e
queste mi sembrano tutte caratteristiche
che nulla hanno a che fare con una
professionista di successo
cosa posso fare l'unica soluzione
mi sembra quella di cercare di
sviluppare anche io gli stessi talenti
gli stessi interessi degli altri membri
della mia famiglia
dopotutto si dice che l'imitazione sia
la più grande forma di ammirazione
giusto quindi famiglia di imprenditori
da una parte famigliari imprenditori
dall'altra sulla cerino fratello deciso
di iscrivermi anche io ad economia
ma l'ingresso nel mondo universitario
non comincia nel migliore nei modi non
venga ammessa alla bocconi dopotutto il
62 era pressoché impossibile però mi
scrivono stessa economia
quando ripenso ai miei l'universitario
mi faccio quasi tenerezza questo bisogno
di dimostrare di dimostrarmi di essere
una persona valida anche io e lo faccio
agendo mia scegliere i corsi che più
difficili più lontani da quello che
veramente mi piace fare statistica
applicata finanza avanzata voglio
costruirmi un curriculum che urli che
sono brava anche io nonostante quel
vergognoso 62 nonostante siano la caccia
non sa che preferisce mangiarsi una
pizza con gli amici piuttosto che andare
a vedersi una mostra ma sono brava sono
brava anche io
ma quanta fatica mi è costato mi ricordo
che a pagina 134 del mio libro di
metodologie e determinazioni
quantitative d'azienda mia sorella ci
aveva disegnato sopra tra le lacrime
perché arrivata a quel punto aveva avuto
ben tre crisi di pianto che mi avevano
spinto aprendo il libro lanciarlo contro
il muro ma la serata non mi manca
anche se senza metterci il cuore di
vento dottoressa magistrale in economia
gestione centrale indirizzo finanza
perché facciamoci del male fino in fondo
ma è arrivato il momento quel momento
che ho sognato ad occhi aperti fin da
quando ero bambina
devo cominciare a lavorare per la
distilleria di famiglia
sono cresciuta ascoltando le gesta
eroiche dei miei nonni
il re e la regina della grappa che hanno
dimostrato al mondo con la creazione
della prima tappa di monovitigno sia una
grappa distillata con solo una tipologia
di vitigno che questo distillato non è
uno schioppo budella ma può diventare se
distillata con metodo artigianale
partendo da materia prima freschissima
l'anima dell'uva nel bicchiere fin da
piccola non riesco ad ascoltare la loro
la nostra storia senza commuovermi
mi sembra quasi una favola impegno
determinazione una storia d'amore c'è
pure la morale quando fai qualcosa con
passione tutto diventa possibile
però adesso tocca a me alla pecora nera
ok in teoria se entrando in azienda quel
titolo di dottoressa magistrale ma io mi
sento più una sopravvissuta la laurea di
economia piuttosto che un economista in
erba cosa posso offrire io all'azienda
di famiglia per fortuna arriva il mio
soccorso la scena è doverosa gavetta il
mio ruolo in azienda brand ambassador in
teoria tappabuchi in pratica veniva
spedita in ogni parte del mondo ad
aziende eventi manifestazioni ma la cosa
incredibile è che non mi dispiace
affatto
sono di nuovo nel mio habitat naturale
in mezzo alla gente la mia empatia si
nutre delle loro espressioni soddisfatta
all'assaggio dei nostri prodotti dei
loro occhi che brillano all'ascolto
della nostra storia
io io mi ritrovo con una nuova energia
una nuova voglia di fare ogni occasione
dopo lavoro diventa buona per imparare
qualcosa di 28mila e diventò bartender
senza rendermene conto
comincio quello che sarebbe stato il
percorso che mi avrebbe avvicinato al
mondo della comunicazione
cominciando a viaggiare per lavoro
accompagnando mills elisabetta ottengo
anche il primo fondamentale appoggio
all'interno dell'azienda
francesca ancora molto da imparare ma il
portata e molto coinvolgente certo
pensate voi facile quando lavori per
l'azienda di mamma è vero lavorare per
l'azienda di famiglia ha decisamente i
suoi vantaggi ma anche alle sue
difficoltà la tua famiglia i tuoi
collaboratori e tu o tu lo sai benissimo
sei lì per diritto di nascita non per
merito ma un conto è lavorare per
l'azienda di famiglia
un conto è che i tuoi collaboratori e la
tua famiglia stimino essi fininho del
lavoro che tu stai facendo e viaggiando
per lavoro ho cominciato ad avere anche
le passò ad ufficiali dei social
aziendali mi servivano per raccontare
quella che era la storia del nostro
brand fuori dall'italia
ogni volta che creo e condivido il
contenuto sento sento una vibrazione una
sorta di battito d'ali fra panza e cuore
una sensazione familiare che mi sembra
di ricordare
voglio capirne di più di quella
sensazione ma so che per poterlo fare ho
bisogno di un titolo qualcosa che
certifica che sono in grado di farlo
decido così di iscrivermi ad un master
sulla social media communication
dopolavoro
chiamatelo destino chiamate la fortuna
ma finisco il mazza a pochi mesi dall
ottantesimo compleanno della regina
della grappa mia nonna gianola solo a
pensarlo sento di nuovo quel battito
d'ali stavolta meno timido perché sapete
mia nonna è quel tipo di donna che ha
sempre organizzato le feste per gli
altri e mai per sé e anche per il suo
ottantesimo compleanno ci aveva impedito
l'organizzazione di qualsiasi festa ma
l'idea mi arriva come un fulmine a ciel
sereno ci ha impedito qualsiasi tipo di
festa fisica non ha detto nulla riguardo
ad una festa digitale come mi viene in
mente questa cosa quel patti totali
diventa una fiamma che vi prende tutto
il petto che non riesco più a contenere
per organizzare una sorpresa devo farle
capire come in 80 anni di vita con il
suo entusiasmo il suo amore per il
lavoro toccato cambiato ispirato persone
in tutto il mondo chiamo giornalisti
scrittori filosofi imprenditori
scienziati star mix oro di sgattoni e
addirittura la squadra di calcio
dell'udinese e chiedo loro di mandarmi
un video di auguri tra gli 80 anni della
regina della grappa sui social lancio
l'ashtag gianola 80 e in attesa del suo
compleanno cominciano a e rara di tutte
le imprese compiute nel mondo della
distillazione non dalla regina della
gatta
i risultati sono insperati articoli
sulle prime pagine delle più importanti
testate nazionali
il giannola 80 citato in televisione ma
fra tutte la cosa che più mi ha dato
soddisfazione è stata una le lacrime di
tura gioia di mia nonna di fronte la
sorpresa che lo avevo preparato
chi mai l'avrebbe detto la mia prima
campagna social di successo si basa su
quella caratteristica che più pensavo
sarebbe stata inutile per il mondo del
lavoro la creatività affettiva
nel momento in cui
capisco che quello che stavo creando
avevo un valore percepito anche
all'esterno comincerà a fidarmi di nuovo
a quel battito d'ali da cui mi facevo
guidare da bambina e più comuni che più
mi rendo conto che quel sentimento
d'affetto che ho bisogno di provare per
dare il via la mia creatività
lui lo provo solo per i singoli membri
della mia famiglia ha tenuta in azienda
perché la mia azienda e la mia famiglia
la mia famiglia la mia azienda per me
comunicare la grappa è diventato una
sorta di bisogno primario come bere come
mangiare voglio voglio che gli italiani
siano orgogliose quanto lo sono io di
questo distillato che non rappresenta
solo la storia di sei generazioni della
mia famiglia ma dell'italia intera
e così comincia a guardare al mondo con
sugli occhi e il filtro grappa ogni cosa
un piatto un film una canzone tutto può
diventare fonte di ispirazione per
raccontare questo meraviglioso
distillato però mi rendo conto che
questa un tipo di comunicazione di
tratti sconvolgente per il settore e so
che un errore su internet può costare la
reputazione dell'intero brand per questo
deciso che la cosa migliore da fare sia
quella di utilizzare i miei profili
social personali come una sorta di test
di cavia per vedere come reagiva al
pubblico
mettermi in gioco in prima persona è
stata la cosa che mi ha dato più
soddisfazioni di tutta la mia vita che
mi ha portata a diventare
l'influenza e la gatta un titolo che non
pensavo neanche potesse esistere
oggi vi parlo con una consapevolezza
nuova
so che devo tutto alla mia famiglia
alle cinque generazioni di distillatori
che mi hanno preceduta a quella sana
sete di riscatto che mi è venuta 19 anni
a tutti i corsi master che ho fatto per
sentirmi degna dell'azienda e della
famiglia che rappresento
ma sono sicura di una cosa
se sono qui su questo palco oggi
non è né per i corsi né per le
certificazioni che ho fatto
se sono qui è perché
in questo percorso di crescita
personale e lavorativa ho dato la
possibilità al mio entusiasmo la mia
empatia la mia creatività affettiva
tutte caratteristiche che pensavo essere
assolutamente di serie b e che non mi
avrebbero mai portata da nessuna parte
la possibilità di brillare
alla francesca di 19 anni che piange
disperata di fronte alla lettera di non
ammissione della bocconi
direi
tirate su e rimboccati le maniche perché
a volte la strada per arrivare al
livello successivo prevede
necessariamente anche qualche caduta ma
fra una decina d'anni se tu ti impegni
quella stessa università che non ti ha
accettato come studentessa che chiamerà
tenere una lezione
raccontare il tuo caso di personal
branding come esempio di comunicazione
di successo perché il next level
estremamente personale a soddisfazioni
difficoltà che sono legate in maniera
intense che il nostro percorso non è
inferiore o superiore a quello degli
altri è semplicemente diverso il next
level della pecora nera comincia con un
semplice e rivoluzionario atto quello di
smettere di guardare al proprio colore
come un difetto da correggere
ma cominciando a considerarlo una
bellissima opportunità da cogliere
[Musica]
sì